right here now with more on biden the
war in ukraine vladimir putin well south
carolina senator lindsey graham let's
start with the economy senator it can't
get any worse than this you know the
party that says they have a monopoly on
of compassion for the poor and the
middle class in this country they are
decimating the middle class bloomberg
reports that what you paid for all of
your goods and services last year is now
5
200
more this year
what can the republicans do if anything
unless they take back the house and
senate to stop this
well number one inflation is the biggest
threat to the working class it's a
nightmare for working people what can
republicans do make democrats vote on
finishing the wall when it comes to
illegal immigration change policy of
biden go back to the trump policy make
democrats vote on energy independence if
we have the house and the senate we need
an american first agenda and drive votes
have debates and votes about policy
changes that would secure our border
grow our economy
reduce our reliance on foreign oil
that's what we need to do is go on
offense if we get the house in the
senate with an agenda that makes sense
we have mass graves we have
men women and children dead in the
street with their luggage trying to
escape ukraine marry a pole it's it's a
city that's been wiped off the map by
vladimir putin uh they say well he's
pulling back from keeve but yet he's
bombing them worse than ever
and i yeah there are two things that
need to be done and at the nato summit
joe biden had a disaster
you know he had to be
corrected by his own team over and over
again but all they really need to do
with two things arm the ukrainians
they'll fight themselves no american
boots on the ground and two they've got
to get
western european and nato countries off
of russia's oil and gas and they set up
a task force how about they come up with
a solution not a task force
well let's look at it this way i've been
on our show since this war began and
hats off to you and your team for
bringing this war home uh to the
american people so we can see the
bravery of the ukrainian people i was
told as a member of the senate this war
would be over in four days that's how
badly our intelligence community and the
body administration missed this five
weeks into this war putin's hold on
russia is cracking
and the russian army is breaking and why
is that because the ukrainian people
have fought like tigers that's the good
news the bad news is five weeks into
this war they still don't have jets that
they need to take the fight to putin and
they're now requesting tanks and the
biden administration is saying no but
one thing i want to tell you on this
show president zielinski has asked the
western powers france great britain the
united states to guarantee the
sovereignty of ukraine when this war
comes to an end and putin is losing
control if we get a peace agreement
zielinski's asking us the united states
great britain and france to give
security guarantees mutual defense or
treaties like we have with japan and
australia i think we should do that i
think we should do that we cannot allow
putin have one inch of land and we
cannot not allow amen uh ukraine to
unilaterally disarm that would be that
would be beyond stupid senator good to
see you thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else